ich hoffe es doch eine frage an dich ist
mit welcher eigenschaft die josef kommst
du am wenigsten zu recht
eine kleine macke kleine marotten es
würde mich mal interessieren mich auf
einer einfach freuen ich bin ungeduldig
und da komm ich nicht mit lahm und ich
muss manchmal einfach langsamer und
geduldiger sein das habe ich echt
gemerkt weil es geht nicht immer alles
so schnell wie man das selber will da
musst du einfach oft etwas mehr geduld
an den tag legen auch beim reden ich bin
also ein
das fällt mir schwer und das ist meine
macke und ich arbeite daran heute bei
diesem interview versuche ich geduldig
zu sein und ruhig zu reden das ist
ernsthaft singen ich hab ne macke dass
diese ungeduld aber es ist ja auch die
zeiten sind man muss alles um an sich
schnell machen wenn im internet nicht
schnell genug bist nie aber eigentlich
so ein interview ist ja wasser mehr
arbeitszeit lassen kann und ich habe
manchmal das gefühl ich müsste innerhalb
von einer minute zehn minuten lang
erklären und aus dem grunde überschlägt
sich das auch ganz oft also manchmal
musste einfach mal ein bisschen größer
werden